Britain's new Prime Minister says the
decision to leave the European Union is
final but how will that process work my
guests here in Brussels is Daniel Hannan
conservative MEP and one of the driving
forces in the leave campaign but how
honest was his campaign and what happens
if he can't deliver on his promises
Daniel Hannan welcome to conflicts sir
thank you
we were leading light of the vote leave
campaign you helped run what former
Prime Minister John Major called a
deceitful campaign verging on the
squalid do you recognize your campaign
from that description well obviously not
I mean we make it up woody on the other
side so of course those very respected
former statesmen you know in every
campaign that I've ever been involved
with and I'm sure in every campaign team
that you've ever covered there have been
good and bad arguments on both sides and
I think this one was no exception but it
wasn't just good and bad was talking
about what he said a whole galaxy of
inaccurate and frankly untrue
information voters were being misled by
a deceitful campaign well should we go
through some of the things that were
said in the campaign and that have
turned out well I want to come to the
moon right in some kind of order but
just before we leave that point you
never stretched a fact in this campaign
in every campaign some people have and
no I don't think I ever did but some
people on both sides used good and bad
arguments but you saw people and vote
leave using bad arguments the whole
country was involved in this campaign so
of course they were good and bad
arguments that's not an excuse for
misleading people is it I don't think
I've misled it what about your campaign
leading right of the campaign some
people who were campaigning for leave
out use bad argument you bring them in
did you want to rein them in in life we
are responsible for what we do right
we're not responsible for every ally who
might have reached the same position as
us your vote leave campaign strategy
versus the strategy you help please do
well here are a number of things that
were said during the campaign that I
think may now be fairly decried as false
we were told that there would be an
emergency budget that they'd have to be
emergency tax rises we're now being told
they'll be tax cuts we were told that
our immigration officers that the French
government have said that's not what the
other side said I'm only going to hold
you responsible for what you said
let's do cross first with with what
appear to be radically conflicting
claims by you and other leading lights
in your campaign right after the vote
you caused something of a stir on
television by saying that you favored
the free movement of workers to and from
the UK it means free movement of labour
you said it doesn't mean you citizenship
my question is at what point did you
declare in the campaign vote brexit
it'll mean Freeman's were out at every
make every give me one example if you'll
allow me to I will tell yes on that very
program sitting around that very table
with that very same interviewer at the
start of the campaign I had said exactly
the same thing I written a book called
why vote leave which sets it all out
which sold 20,000 copies I hardly think
like me accusing this people mean free
labor yes it does very clearly what page
age how after works and how after
although not although no country is
going to be an exact model for Britain
provides a broad template for how at
least in the medium term a post EU
Britain might retain some advantageous
links with our immediate neighbors and
allies well this is free movies that
advantageous links it's free movement
it's what people were voting to get you
know 73 we joined the EC and we accepted
the rule that if you have a firm job
offer in another country you may take it
up and that's reciprocal right and I
don't remember there being any
complaints about that
now when Maastricht came in that was a
shift what you something pained on and
and by the way your fellow vote leave
campaign and Michael Gove who want to
become Prime Minister had another view
entirely I will end free movement he
said well never dream on both sides
there were coalition's but the idea that
you couldn't get your stories together
you're a go for free movement and he's
against we very clearly said that we
will take back control now taking back
control of immigration in my book can
mean only one thing which is that a
foreign court will no longer get to
determine who can reside in the UK or
who can enter the allow me to answer
having
taken back control there is nothing to
stop an independent British Parliament
from reaching whatever bilateral or
multilateral treaties with other
countries as directed by the public for
example we've had free movement with the
Irish Republic since 1923 we did that as
a sovereign country oh you're getting
off the subject of the question my
question was
Gove is pledging to end free movement in
line he says with the promises made by
the campaign you said the campaign
didn't make that promise you talked
about controlling you by contrast saying
we never made the promise and free
movement we will sing you back control
that does not mean zero immigration and
I don't think anyone can claim that we
said it would mean zero immigration we
hardly sneaked this out in the small
print at the final debate Boris Johnson
went out of his way to say I'm and you
say free movement it's not the same
thing is it freedom to take up a job
offer is not the same as freedom to
settle in a country in poverty no wonder
people are confused aren't they well by
your campaign because you've got two
different voices we had hope says he's
ending free movement you say free
movement is it him because maybe I need
to explain that it's a referendum there
were people from the far left there were
people from the centre there working
from the center right there were trade
unions campaigning against the were
people from is to take control what we
then do having taken back control will
be a matter for Parliament that's how
democracy works you were upset by this
row back because you said on Twitter
chaps look what I said throughout the
campaign it's all on Twitter YouTube I
was for more control not for minimal
immigration right yes you wanted more
control sure but at no point did you
advertise what you later blurted out on
the BBC brexit will still mean free
movement of labour I advertise it on
Twitter you actually said Breck about it
breaks it means free movement of labour
yes well you certainly didn't do a video
which I made here about how the European
free trade association works how it
means accepting the Four Freedoms while
bringing back sovereignty in other areas
this is not something that I try to
sneak out quietly the campaign the
campaign of somebody else said something
else well do you know what is
referendum you have you behold on
painting together now you say you were
campaigning separately which all the one
should be thinking by Wow agreed on
united by one united by taking back
control so that it's for britain to
decide the whole purpose of taking back
atom like we are in control - Michael
shall we exercise that control is up to
a sovereign Parliament that Tim is what
democracy means it means that instead of
foreign courts telling us what to do we
decide through our own national
democratic institutions and mechanisms
that's the thing we all agreed on that's
the thing we're now going to deliver
okay but it's going to look very
different if one of them says yes that
will be okay robust debate within our
democratic system and the British people
will decide that not having any we're
gonna get your stories straight before
our story was very straight it was those
are the key differences okay alright
let's look at the aftermath you said I'm
in all of this promise Marcus chaos you
said five days ago this promised market
cast hasn't really happened in the UK
our stock exchange is back to where it
was before the vote so everything's fine
yeah III know if you look at what Rose
tinted view isn't it if you if you look
at what we were being told before that
you know that the German Finance
Minister who now says well we'll have to
find a special deal for Britain he was
asked but you said in the campaign it
means out that Britain will be treated
like any third country said yeah well
that's what George Osborne told me to
say you know the President of the United
States said that you'll be at the back
of the queue now they're saying we'll
have a deal with you before we have one
with the EU who is now there say the
White House is saying the White House
has conspicuously refused to repeat that
back of the queue line it didn't the
Seekers have said we will do this much
more easily than will do that's not on
behalf of the US government
so when you say they're saying yes it's
won the trial and after meeting when
Barack Obama was invited to repeat that
back of the queue remark he
conspicuously home you mentioned the
Germans look at some of the effects that
are coming into focus here more than a
third of German businesses plan to
reduce investment in Britain and one in
four to cut jobs in the UK this
according to a poll by the dih k which
is Germany's Chamber of Commerce the
figures it says show that Britain as a
business location will clearly be
weakened by brexit well obviously I
guess job to be lost obviously I
disagree with that I think that five
years from now Britain will be
flourishing as never before and people
will look back and wonder why we didn't
do this you can't get the Germans to say
that at least see what actually happens
after all this time to model what you
read bit more careful about quoting
surveys at least six property funds have
been unable to meet withdraw requests
after the brexit vote and have stopped
investors leaving their UK property
funds in any week you're gonna have some
good economic news and some bad economy
news this is absolutely a decision of
tough appeals now not to leave Wales
that was tied absolutely to bricks it
the decision to carry on making things
at Pinewood Studios that was tied
absolutely to bricks it you know there
is good and bad news there are winners
and losers in everything but I really do
want her to realize or lose as you said
in your book page 13 of the intro no
jobs will be lost
look my job will be lost I mean apart
from you said those are the British
bureaucrats and any piece including me I
have no jobs will be laughs absolutely
no doubt that Britain will be a more
global more deregulated more free trade
five years from jobs where for you loss
overall employment you couldn't ever
give a promise like that you couldn't
ever deliver on a promise like that that
not a single job will be lost because it
breaks it because it breaks it apart
from the Eurocrats already telling you
they're gonna run informed plan to cut
jobs in the UK what are you doing let's
see let's see what happens because I as
I say let's see what happens Britain
will remain a global country interested
and involved with the affairs of every
continent including Europe I don't think
there's going to be any prejudicial
change to our commercial relations with
our European allies who will remain our
friends and allies in any circumstances
but I think there will now be a long
overdue emphasis on our relations with
non EU markets which of course are the
markets that are growing the fastest the
Virgin billionaire Richard Branson's
also warning thousands of jobs will be
lost five days after the referendum he
met with a group of Chinese business
partners
busted heavily in the UK and are now
going to stop investing and withdraw the
investments they'd made but you think
it's all father so far that hasn't been
happening there are actually more
studying since the vote than before this
is the intentions but how many people
before the vote including the chairman
of Barclays including including Siemens
suggested that they might revisit
investment decisions and have now simps
the vote road back from what they said
during the campaign because they were
obviously under some pressure from the
remain side I think very quickly a lot
of these scare stories are going to be
exposed as what they were you think
based on what they're saying now that
they were saying one thing before the
vote when they were trying to pressure
us into voting to remain in now that the
vote is out of the way they're saying
well of course we're still committed of
course we're gonna carry on investing
here and in the cases that I've just
cited Tata Steel and Pinewood they're
now making additional commitments
because of precision because of the more
competitive exchange rate no jobs will
be lost and we're supposed to believe
that you are the keeper of the sacred
trees no I mean no wonder Neil Ferguson
the history professor at Harvard when he
was reviewing your book he said glossy
you were glossing over the risks of
brexit in ways that would disgrace and
undergraduate examining on the other
side it doesn't matter he's a respected
historian it's his view glossing over
anybody who says no jobs are gonna be
lost well obviously it's not my view I
would not have been inviting people to
fire me from a very well remunerated
position if I didn't think that it would
be the interest of the UK economy as a
whole and that five years from now will
be a much more prosperous country your
your campaign rubbished most experts
that and continues to rubbish most
experts that think differently don't you
I mean Michael Gove said the British
people have had enough of experts
famously the Institute for Fiscal
Studies in may your campaign called it a
paid up arm of the European Commission
you stand by that actually do get money
from European 10% as yet from the
European Research Council that funds
academic research around the world 10%
but the prime makes that will fully
paid-up a problem so you exaggerate the
campaign the IFS report is that they fed
in all of the data and assumptions that
were produced by some think tanks
and Institute's that were much more
heavily dependent on a new funding I
think we saw a group think among
economists in exactly the same way that
we did about joining but you don't stand
by this fader palm of the European
Commission and I think I think this
isn't it I think their assessment was
wrong
that's so your campaign was wrong on
this obviously they're not fully funded
by he her fame Commission of course they
paid our bomb of the European context
adoration isn't correct okay so you
criticize your campaign for that Barack
Obama well he was criticized as virus
Johnson said that that was down to the
part Kenyan president ancestral dislike
of the British Empire
that was what decided his view you stand
by that - you can spend the whole
interview asking me to stand by things
that I didn't say I think it's important
to know whether you stomach I don't
think so I mean I think you brought the
criticism of Mark Carney the governor of
the Bank of England I mean I mean there
are cou smeared your campaign smeared
you if you ask me from my own view
rather than ask me for somebody else I
think there's a huge criticism to be
made of Barack Obama's intervention and
it was that he was urging on the UK a
policy that he would never dream of
following for his own country you know
he would never accept a superior
jurisdiction for the Organization of
American States able to strike down laws
of Congress he would never accept a
pan-american peso being you know
administered by some central bank in
Havana or whatever and so he was urging
us to accept limitation miss his ideas
and put them down to the fact of his
part Kenyan ancestral dislike of empire
is not only rude and it's it's it's I
think it was unfair although your
campaigns being it was unfair although
it is most Connie I wanted to move on it
is only fair that Barack Obama in his
book in his own biography talks about
reasons why there are why there was an
ancestral dislike of the British Empire
Mark Carney you rubbished him and really
led some said he intentionally
encouraged financial instability I do
wish you'd cheer up a bit yeah and then
and then Kate that is quite a different
point then came a vote leave video
you on the campaign committee presumably
signed off on this smearing him for his
previous career at Goldman Sachs
and putting up the caption over his face
some say Goldman Sachs is still pulling
the strings today that was tendentious
and prime aphasia was defamatory I think
there is an absolutely legitimate point
to be made about the way in which
Goldman Sachs and other mega banks were
pouring money into the remained campaign
to defend their own narrow interests
rather than the interests of financial
services more broadly let alone the UK
popular it was suggesting that he was
having his strings pulled by Goldman
if the other side is taking money from
Goldman Sachs it is absolutely fair for
us to point out that Goldman Sachs has
invested millions over many years in
getting a regulatory regime in Brussels
that suits them and hurts their rivals
and that was why they were so determined
to stay and it was nothing to do with
the interests of a well the words some
say as you know are the last resort of a
journalist who doesn't have the facts
Sunday they were used that expression
was used the whole time by Pravda in his
vest ear during the Cold War some say
here's something that someone else has
said you're responsible for it miss you
are a leader you were a leader of the
vote leave campaign you on the campaign
committee you helped chart the strategy
every week every week you sat down with
these people so you have some
responsibility for this don't you like
like the pledge to divert the 350
million pounds a week you claim Britain
sends to the EU divert it to the
National Health Service
I absolutely that which turned out not
to be absolutely standby the 350 million
pound a week figure that is a gross
figure and obviously people understand
the difference we can grow some net they
understand that if you ask what your
salary is it's the gross not but the
chair of the UK Statistics Authority
said the statement was potentially
misleading I disagree with that
I am absolutely prepared to defend that
figure if you say to somebody you know
what's basic great income tax they will
say to you it's 20 P in the past they
weren't say oh well I'd better deduct
all the stuff that I get but he said the
use of the 350 million pounds figure
appears to be a gross figure does not
take into account the rebate or other
flows from the EU to the UK public
sector or flows to non public sector
bodies this statement is potentially
misleading but you went on using it in
yes I stand by you mind being misleading
I don't think it was misleading no I
disagree with that and what about the
going to the National Health Services
this idea of sending let's give our NHS
the 350 million pounds the EU takes
every week well if a lever had won the
prime ministership I think both Boris
Johnson and Michael Gove and indeed and
rail Edson had made clear that they
would give that money to the NHS because
they felt bound but you might be had Ian
Duncan Smith also of your campaign said
oh that was just an extrapolation it's
not a broken promise I never said that
through the course of the issue what I
said will be able to spend the lion's
share of that money this poster was very
clear let's give our NHS National Health
Service the 350 million bands that the
EU takes every week let's give them that
money not an extrapolation not a bit of
it here is it it was clear well may
Arthur please people understand the
difference between a general election
and a referendum when you vote leave
you're not voting to elect a new
government you're mandating the
government to leave like you instruct a
lawyer you're instructing the government
to get us out in doing so you're freeing
up the money that we're currently giving
to the EU or at least you will be when
exit takes effect obviously it is for a
future government to determine how that
money is going to be spent people are
perfectly capable of understanding that
had they elected one of the leaders of
the probe leave campaign I think they
would have elected as leader and as
Prime Minister someone who would have
felt morally obliged to stick by that
promise but what is clear is that the
money will then be there for Parliament
to spend on whatever combination there
was your campaign afterwards say well we
weren't gonna give it that was just an
extrapolation that's not an excuse for a
poster that says quite clearly let's
give the 350 million to the to the
National Health Service you can read our
difficult as many ways as you like it's
still gonna have the same outcome yet
people understood the issue and they
voted to take that control
they may have voted what about Turkey
your post at Turkey is joining the EU
vote leave poster presented as
unassailable fact Turkey is joining the
EU no doubt no caveat it's going to
happen it's not true is it something you
don't know whether it's true or not I
think it was a fair thing that it was to
say that it was both UK government
policy and EU you didn't say you didn't
say that you said it's going to when
it's happening the British government
and the European authorities were saying
that it's going to happen already made
clear that she'd vote against it well
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens but the day after our referendum
the European Commission confirmed that
it was still on course it may have
confirmed this still on course but
Angela Merkel has said it's not going to
happen if you were interested in the
truth over Turkey you would have
corrected what penny Morden said denied
that Britain had a veto over Turkey's
accession to the European Union
and that was left standing a penny was
incorrect about that yeah but nobody
corrected her you didn't get up and say
that was incorrect well why would you
let something like that stand when it
achieved a lot of publicity people say
oh this isn't true this isn't true but
your campaign stayed silent because
presumably you hoped that somebody would
actually accept it as truth I don't
think so I think people completely get I
mean what all this comes down to is
you're saying basically the voters were
very thick and that they were led astray
misled by unscrupulous I'm saying these
nice things mental opinion of my fellow
countrymen than that like I said were
supposed to read between the lines when
they like I said right at the beginning
there are good and bad argument on all
sides in every campaign there were good
and bad arguments on the remain side and
on the leave side by and large you can
rely on people to suss out where the
truth lies they do so in most general
elections they did so on this occasion
so they were supposed to read the line
between the lines they weren't supposed
to take the ads full face interview
throwing at me things that other people
have said right but I'm happy to say I'm
just quoting the exact words that I see
you're planning to then all right carry
on no but the exact words that were on
your posters on the post of this age
turkeys on his way to membership I think
when the
European authorities and the British
copies on his way says Turkey is joining
fine other words that was stating the
policy of no it wasn't the UK it was but
you know as well as I do it's very
unlikely to know I disagree I think it
particularly with DS design because the
only way in which it will not happen is
if the UK in this renegotiation
establishes some kind of looser status
some kind of association with the EU
that is inside the market but outside
political union then it may well be that
Turkey and some of the after countries
and some other non EU states might wish
to copy that relationship and to follow
us into a similar Association which I
think would solve a number of problems
and would make brexit a mutually
beneficial process that brings
advantages to the remaining EU as well
as to the UK all right how long does
Britain have to go on living in chaos
and uncertainty political chaos economic
uncertainty which of course is bad for
growth Goes Down it's bad for people on
a holiday this summer it's bad for
imports because they keep rising I I
disagree I think the pound was hugely
overvalued I think it was long do a
correction and just as in 1992 and 2008
the correction when it happened was the
prelude to strong economic growth and by
the way of all the promises of economic
chaos that we were given by the remain
side the only thing that has come true
is this long overdue decline in the
value of sterling all of the other
things that we were told would happen
that collapse in the stock exchange and
the emergency tanks license all of that
has been forgotten what would have to
happen along the way for you to say we
got it wrong sorry
oh if I shouldn't shouldn't have done
this I'm on the wrong side because some
people released this saying they voted
the wrong way and more people the other
way are saying that they should have
voted well not according to opinion no
okay well the one poll I saw three
percent of leave voters regret addition
four percent of remain mobile conducted
by ITV in Cardiff University ask people
to imagine another referendum same
question showed a single percent swing
towards these are the same polls that
kept showing remain ahead all the way
through Ida for you to buy now learnt
not to your polls at me that the test is
going to be where what's Britain gonna
be like after we've come out because
obviously there's a procedure to go
through we want to make sure that we're
fair to the other men
States and then we get this right that
we get advantageous terms for all sides
what's breaking up the Union worth
breaking up I think we can strengthen
the UK I lay the UK UK you know I well I
think we can't disregard the fact that
the UK is a partnership of Nations two
of the four nations returned remain
majorities and therefore we can't wish
that fact away we have to find a common
negotiating position that all of us can
at least live with that may go too far
for some and not far enough for others
but around which a consensus can form in
Scotland and Northern Ireland as well as
in England and Wales all right tell you
Helen we have to leave it there thanks
very much indeed
you